[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEEVANA HEGDE: Hi, everyone.
I'm Jeevana Hegde.
DEOK FILHO: And I'm Deok Filho.
JEEVANA HEGDE: And we're
both customer engineers
at Google Cloud.
And we're so glad to have
you back to another episode
of "Technical Guide
for Startups," where
we are creating a series of
videos for technical enablement
to start, build, and grow
your businesses successfully
and sustainably on Google Cloud.
DEOK FILHO: In our
previous video,
we talked about
Compute Engine and how
to configure it appropriately.
Now we're on the sixth episode,
Networking Configurations.
Let's dive in.
JEEVANA HEGDE: In
this video, we're
going to understand
Google's Global Network,
do an overview of VPC
Networking, firewall rules,
and load balancing, and
understand these concepts
better with a few
quick demonstrations
based on the instances
we've deployed
in our previous "Compute with
Google Compute Engine" video.
If you haven't watched that,
please do check it out.
We've linked it in the
description box below.
We will then cover a
customer success story
and wrap up with some
actionable next steps.
So without any
further ado, let's
get right on to the video.
For the past 15 years,
Google has been building out
one of the fastest, one
of the most powerful,
and one of the most highest
quality cloud infrastructures
on the planet.
Google runs its own
data center to data
center high-throughput
fiber backbone,
and traffic travels
as far as possible
on Google's own network.
And the result is a global
network connecting our data
centers to each other and
to all the major cities
across the globe.
Think about it.
This network is so reliable
that, for many people,
checking to see if they
can get to google.com
is how they test
their home network.
Most cloud providers use what's
called hot potato routing.
This is when you're
sending out traffic
from their infrastructure,
they offload it
to the public internet
as soon as possible.
This is like a hot
potato that they
want to get off their hands.
Google Cloud as well
provides this option
in the standard networking
tier, but we also
do things differently.
In Google Cloud's
premium networking tier,
we use something called the
cold potato routing technique,
where we keep that traffic on
Google Cloud's private network
for as long as
possible and exit it
to the public internet at the
location closest to the end
user, usually in the
same town or city.
This enables us to offer you
with better reliability, better
performance, and more security.
And this is possible due to
the Google's global network
we've been talking
about, the big benefits
being high performance, reduced
latency, and superior network
quality, leading to a
delightful user experience.
Hence, the Premium Tier is the
recommended and default tier,
as it delivers your traffic
over Google's global backbone
network.
This global network also paves
way to some unique features,
like global load
balancing, CDN, and more.
We'll cover some
of these as we go.
DEOK FILHO: Coming up
next, VPC networking.
A VPC, or Virtual Private Cloud,
is your virtual global network
in Google Cloud.
As you can see from
this image, they
are created within
projects and are made up
of subnets, which are regional.
VPCs enable private
communication
between Google Cloud
regions natively,
allowing you to keep
a fault tolerant
in highly available
network by default.
When creating a VPC in
the Google Cloud Console
or through the Cloud SDK,
you can choose from two
custom subnet creation modes--
auto subnet mode, which
creates a subnet for each
of Google Cloud's
existing regions,
or custom subnet
mode, which allows
you to create a subnet for
each of the regions you'd like.
Creating a VPC with
custom subnet mode
is our recommended
best practice.
Let's take a look at
how to create a VPC.
Log on to the Google
Cloud Console.
Select the list view of Google
products, and open VPC Network.
Notice that there is
already a network created
called "default," which
spans all regions and is
of type auto subnet mode.
Let's now create a new network
using custom subnet mode.
Select Create VPC Network.
Give it an identifiable name,
making sure to select Custom
under Subnet Creation Mode.
In the new subnet box,
you'll be able to create
multiple subnets.
First, choose a name.
Select a region
from the dropdown.
And choose a private IP
range for this subnet.
Turn private Google
access on if you
wish to allow VMs in this subnet
to communicate with Google APIs
without needing external IPs.
Then, toggle Flow Logs On if
you'd like to see detailed
logs for your network traffic.
Notice that toggling this
on will incur extra costs.
Repeat these steps
for all the subnets
you wish to create in this VPC.
Finally, choose
Global if you need
to make your newly
created subnets
available to your
on-prem network.
If not, leave Regional selected.
Click Create.
Your VPC will be
provisioned within seconds.
Let's talk a bit
about firewall rules.
Unlike a traditional firewall,
which is a physical appliance
filtering traffic
between subnets,
Google Cloud's firewall rules
provide distributed enforcement
at the virtual networking level.
This means that there
is no performance
bottleneck or
[? singular ?] pointer
failure in using our firewall.
Firewall rules are
included at no extra cost,
and there are no appliances or
operating systems to manage.
Essentially, every
VPC network functions
as a distributed firewall.
Finally, you can think
of GCP firewall rules
as existing not only
between your instances
in other networks, but also
between individual instances
within the same network.
When creating a
firewall rule, you
must specify a few
configurations.
At a basic level,
a firewall rule
needs a target, which
controls the instances
to which the rules apply.
This can be done by specifying
an instance tag, a service
account that's attached
to your instance,
or simply choosing to apply the
rule to all of the instances.
Next, you must choose
the direction of traffic
the rules apply to,
ingress or egress traffic.
The rule can then block or
allow the predetermined flow
of traffic.
Finally, you must specify
either a source or a destination
for the rule to
apply to, depending
on which direction
of traffic you chose.
Let's now take a look at the
creation of a firewall rule.
Let's create a rule that
blocks all incoming traffic
from the internet.
Still in the Google
Cloud Console,
hover over the VPC Network
and select Firewall.
After selecting Create
Firewall Rule, choose a name,
select which network this rule
applies to, and set a priority.
Here, a lower number
means higher priority,
where the highest
priority is denoted by 0.
Because we're trying to
block all incoming traffic
from the internet,
I'll select Ingress
for destination of traffic
and Deny for action on match.
I'll make this rule apply to
all instances in the network.
And in the source IPv4 ranges,
I'll put 0.0.0/0 to represent
any and all traffic, including
that from the public internet.
The final rule is ready,
so now select Create.
Another option for the
configuration of a firewall
rule is to edit a VM instance
directly on the Google Cloud
Console to allow HTTP traffic.
On the Instances
page, click Edit.
Check Allow HTTP traffic.
Then, hit Save.
Once the firewall
rule IS configured,
you'll be able to see it
in the Firewall Rules page,
where its target is
denoted as HTTP-server.
On the Instance page,
you can see a network tag
for this name,
HTTP-server, signifying
the relationship between
the rule and the instance.
JEEVANA HEGDE: In
Google Cloud, we
offer different flavors
of load balancers.
On the global side,
depending on the traffic,
we have load balancers for
HTTP/HTTPS, SSL, and TCP.
On the regional side, we
have network load balancer
and HTTPS a load balancer, both
external and internal facing.
External load balancer
distribute the traffic
coming from the internet to
your Google Cloud VPC network.
On the other hand,
internal load balancer
distribute traffic to instances
inside your Google Cloud.
If your backends are distributed
across multiple regions,
go for the global
Cloud load balancing.
If not, you can choose from the
regional Cloud load balancing
services.
Google Cloud load
balancing is built
on the same frontend-serving
infrastructure
that powers Google.
It supports 1 million-plus
queries per second,
with high performance
and low latencies.
The first picture
shows a load balancing
in a traditional
cloud provider, where
both the load balancer
and the instances
sit in the data center.
The user request
traverses the internet
and finally makes
its way to the load
balancer that's sitting
in the data center
by a cloud provider.
As you can see,
the cloud provider
has no control over the user
experience over the internet.
So there is no way to deliver
low latency or great user
experience.
However, it's different with
Google's global load balancing.
Since the load balancing is
at 80-plus points of presence
around the world,
the user request
only traverses the internet
for a short period of time
until it reaches the closest
Google's Point of Presence,
or PoP.
Beyond that, the load
balancing system and PoPs
dominate the TCP connection
and delivers the request
to the service over Google's
high-quality global network.
The benefits are significant.
To name a few, it provides
reduced latency and improved
throughput for your users.
It also helps in serving
static casual content
from multiple points
near your users.
Now let's go over
a demonstration
of how to enable external
HTTPS load balancer
for your application.
We're going to take
into consideration
the application we deployed
in our previous video.
Go to the Google Cloud Console,
and your Home page opens up.
Select Network Services and
Load Balancing, or simply type
"load balancing" in your
search and select this.
You can see your existing load
balancers here and your backend
and frontend options here.
As we had deployed a backend
in our previous video,
we see that option listed here.
Now let's go ahead and
create a load balancer
by clicking on
Create Load Balancer.
You can choose
your load balancers
to be HTTP, HTTPS load balancer,
a TCP load balancer, or a UDP
load balancer.
We've already gone
over this, and know
that you'll be
choosing whether you
want them to be internal
or external once you
start configuring them.
Right now I want to configure
an external HTTP/HTTPS load
balancer.
So let me do that by clicking
on Start Configuration for this.
So here I choose whether
it's from the internet
as an external facing,
or between my VMs
as an internal facing.
Like I said, I want this
to be external facing,
so I'm going to
choose From Internet.
Now give it a name and
choose a backend service.
You can either create a back
end service directly here,
or choose something that
was previously created.
I'm going to choose
the one which I
created in the previous video.
As you can see, another tab
got updated automatically.
Let's quickly review this,
the host and path rules
here, which
essentially tells you
that you can load balance
to backend services or Cloud
Storage bucket, which is the
object storage option on Google
Cloud.
And because I picked the backend
service, this was updated.
For your frontend
configuration, assign a name.
Select whether you want
an HTTP or HTTPS protocol.
Let's just say HTTP.
And choose your network
tier, like from what
we discussed earlier.
You can choose whether you
want it to be an ephemeral IP,
select the one that was
created in the frontend
in the previous video, or choose
to create a new one as well.
Give it a name and select that.
Select your IP version
and port number.
Then we leave it as is.
If nothing is chosen
in this section,
the defaults are taken.
Now in this section, I get
to review my configurations.
And now click on Create.
Now if you refresh it, you can
see that your load balancer
is here.
Now that we've created
a load balancer,
let's quickly test it out.
Click on this to get to
the load balancer details.
Then go to Monitoring to
see the load balancing.
We see this.
Now let me go back
to the Details,
pick up the frontend
external IP address,
and go to a new tab or window.
I've just opened up
an incognito window.
Here, let me put
in the IP address.
And as you can see, you can
see the guestbook application
that we had deployed.
Now let me randomly
put in some load.
Now, let's go back and
check our Monitoring queue.
You see that there's
a load coming
in from different
continents across the globe
to the frontend and
hitting it and moving
to the assigned backend.
Now let me go back and add some
intense amount of load again.
Let's quickly refresh
this, and here you go.
You can see that there's so much
more load coming in from Asia
as opposed to America.
And similarly, you can also
load balance it further
amongst different backends
internally and monitor them.
So we successfully
created and tested
our external load
balancer, bringing us
to the end of this demo.
DEOK FILHO: Google Cloud's
network is impressive,
so let's see what one of our
customers built on top of it.
PacketFabric is
a private network
that provides secure,
reliable on-demand services
between customers and their
cloud service providers,
whether private or public.
They help their customers
automate their network
connectivity in order
to move their data
from one place to another.
PacketFabric leverages Google's
network to offer a globally
interconnected
Network-as-a-Service platform
to its customers.
Additionally, Google Cloud's
highly performant VPC
networking helps
PacketFabric's customers
to build, provision, and change
their network infrastructure
quickly and painlessly.
In summary, you're
a few clicks away
from leveraging Google Cloud's
powerful and secure network
to run your most exciting
and demanding applications.
Thank you for joining us on
this episode about networking
configurations.
To continue exploring the
vastness of Google Cloud
networking, check out
our suggestions here,
and don't hold back on
clicking on the links
in the description.
JEEVANA HEGDE: That brings
us to the end of this video.
But don't worry, we have
some exciting content for you
in our upcoming video.
In our next video,
we're going to look
at the big picture of databases
for Google Cloud, deep dive
into Cloud SQL, and
do some demonstrations
for Cloud SQL, along
with some integrations,
and learn how to optimize it.
We'll also be discussing a
sample gaming application
architecture and go over a
success story of a startup
customer.
Don't forget to like this video
and subscribe to our YouTube
channel.
Hit up the bell
icon to get notified
every time we post a new video.
DEOK FILHO: Bye now.
JEEVANA HEGDE:
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]